[Applaudissements]
voyez un petit nom un appel téléphonique
ah non samedi soit on n'est pas reçu un
appel téléphonique non nature ben oui ça
ne fait pas reçu un appel de quelqu'un
qui est voulais vous parler un agent à
nos gamins qui m'a appelé qui m'a dit
est ce que vous êtes gilles verdez ouais
alors j'ai dit bah non je suis désolé
j'ai raccroché au train d'arriver sur
the voice et il ya un team qui décroche
que des pales numéro donc au bout 3g je
décroche dit vous êtes gilles verdez
j'ai dit bah non je suis désolé vous
vous trompez numéro j'ai raccroché
c'était en fait je vous explique tout
l'histoire gt gt avec ramzy et au malik
bentalha et on voulait il voulait vous
appelez en fait j'ai laissé un moment je
leur ai dit c'est votre numéro et va
fait crâne si vous voulez vous appelez
se faire passer pour le dow et star et
dire à l'eau thierry alonzo diallo
gilles verdez savais que c'était vous
vous alliez d'y renoncer thierry moreau
a en plus tu veux te faire passer pour
gilles verdez on va débuter
voilà ça n'a pas fonctionné la tristesse
du scénario et est en fait je vous
raconte tout et donc ils arrêts et il
n'arrivait pas à faire là bas donc il a
fait oui bonjour c'est jean-pierre
philosophe et voilà il lui a raccroché
direct à la gueule c'est pas la merci
donc je voulais vous dire c'était moi
c'était c'était voilà c'était d'aider
les habits voilà d'accord merci on a
essayé vous appelez vous aussi c'est ce
que ben